[Musica]
e per me un po particolare essere qui
oggi perché parlare della terra è un
argomento complesso the stig ato ampio
io sono state migranti e tante volte
l'ultima volta poco tempo fa sono stato
ospitato venga ospitato dalla vostra
bagni [ __ ] regioni della puglia si dice
sempre che a volte per integrarsi meglio
perché l'integrazione importante non
bisogna fare come i cinesi che fanno le
chinatown e si si distaccano totalmente
dal tessuto che li ospita bisogna
trovare bisogna aprirsi mentalmente alle
novità le nuove opportunità che queste
terre nuove ci danno e al tempo stesso
però trovare conforto nella casa in un
pezzo di casa lontano da casa
oggi o tutt'e due queste cose perché il
tenax mi dà la possibilità di integrarmi
ancora di più con la puglia anche se
foggia oramai è la città che mi ospita
almeno per un po lo speech di oggi e
terra della mia terra ma dicevo ogni
tanto bisogna trovare anche il momento
per trovare quel pezzettino di casa
lontano da casa che ci conforta e questo
senso oggi sono tutte e due le cose
l'integrazione del territorio pugliese
con il tè dax e fortunatamente anche un
luogo che mi ricorda casa mia perché
questo teatro è fatti poi ho saputo da
poco grazie a professor gorgoglione mi
ricorda molto il teatro san carlo ma mi
diceva che effettivamente le mike trans
che l'hanno fatta sono le stesse quindi
perfetto benda l'argomento di oggi che
terra della mia terra parlando di
qualche cosa che sta effettivamente
accadendo nel mondo del design design e
tutte le sue accezioni
io l'ho chiamata globalizzazione
creativa non è un termine
particolarmente originale ed è
volutamente poco originale
può sembrare un ossimoro anche se
semanticamente non lo è ma no è di fatto
perché il mondo della creatività tutto
vuole tranne che la globalizzazione è
semplice il discorso qualunque
espressione creativa che sia l'arte che
sia il design e le sue progettazioni
pensiamo a tutti i prefissi o anche i
suffissi che la parola design fashion
design graphic design interior design
industrial design product design new
york's design e per essere qualcosa di
più vicino a me e graphic design beh in
tutti questi campi viene richiesta
l'originalità un'originalità che sia in
grado di comunicare molto spesso in
maniera sintetica questa originalità
come potete vedere anche da queste slide
un po anche per questo fenomeno strano
che si chiamano social network creativi
si è appiattita verso l'alto il che è un
gran bene
sì appiattita ovviamente verso l'alto
perché io parlo della corea dell'italia
tanto per fare due nomi ma potrei dire
l'america e l'india si guardano l'un
l'altro si ispirano l'un l'altro si
copiano l'un l'altro e quindi tutto è
diventato molto e bridge non sono
un'amante delle parole anglosassoni un
po lo sono ma in questo caso uso lg non
a caso perché avere jules dire meglio
non mediocre c'è questa media molto alta
che ha fatto qualche cosa di positivo
indubbiamente innalzando la qualità però
vero eppure al tempo stesso che noterete
un appiattimento io ho preso proprio due
pezzettini di questi social network per
farvi rendere conto di quanto
l'omogeneità si stia dilagando un'alta
omogeneità certo ma un omogeneità e
allora potrei anche ora invece pensare a
qualche cosa qualche via d'uscita
ho pensato qualche via d'uscita e la via
d'uscita alla propria terra
ma come non è ovvio riferisse alla
propria terra certo che lo è
e ovvio però possiamo anche aggiungere
che per certi versi fino a oggi può
essere almeno parlo da designer è stato
fatto male per certi versi è stato
raccontato male la parola raccontata non
è casuale perché lo vedremo perché è
strano
si no sino a ieri tra le ispirazioni dal
proprio background dalle proprie terre
era qualche cosa di positivo era una
grande risorsa
oggi non lo è più oggi è diventato e lo
grafico è diventato folkloristico a
volte addirittura grottesco perché come
mai diventato e chissà cosa aspetto di
provincialismo questo sapore di
provincialismo
qualcuno si è gestito a uscire da questa
da questa impasse per raccontarlo altra
parola fondamentale di oggi utilizzo
un aneddoto successo in italia un grande
regista come francis ford coppola che
mette stava girando il padrino parte
seconda in sicilia credo parte seconda
non so in quale paese in una vecchina di
quel probabilmente a lutto stretto come
si usa forse era mai si stava da quelle
parti sto facendo anche io fotografico
videla truppe lo fermò a gli chiese ma
come mai che state facendo qui e di
spaccio il regista se ti vuoi dare
un'indicazione ti voglio dare un
suggerimento la storia nulla conta tutte
come la racconti ora è chiaro che questa
è una estremizzazione ma è una
estremizzazione che vuole trasferire un
concetto chiave importante fondamentale
è vero che la storia conta ma è molto
importante come la si racconta oggi chi
parla bene lo chiama storytelling chiama
che poi la traduzione letterale di
raccontare una storia non è importante
l'importante che forse cominciamo a
pensare a come raccontarle meglio come
facciamo a raccontare meglio qualche
cosa riferendoci alla nostra terra
io qui parlo di evoluzione e fusione
perché evoluzione fusione perché gli
anglosassoni sempre ma prima mi sono
dato questa bella aurea di non aver
non voler riferirmi troppo al mondo
anglosassone poi mi riferisco di nuovo
l'evoluzione della fusione dicevo
riferiamo c'è la nostra terra ma in
modalità evolutiva magari fondendo più
delle culture che sono molto spesso
presenti nella nostra terra
io vengo da napoli chiaramente l'accento
non tradisce una provenienza da bergamo
alta e questa è abbastanza chiaro dicevo
a volte dobbiamo riferirci alla nostra
terra fondendone tante nature come a
volte capita a napoli gli anglosassoni
sempre tornando al discorso di prima
un sarò una piccola formuletta don't
rain 22 uil non reinventare la ruota la
ruota c'è già esiste più perfetta non
può essere ma forse si può evolvere
forse si può migliorare
ed è questa l'indicazione che mi viene
in mente con una mia ex allieva roberta
giornata in poi la sua tesi roberta in
questo caso mi propose un allieva
brillante mi propose una tesi brillante
all'accademia di belle arti di napoli
dove io insegno che il segno web design
quindi una tesi in questo caso specifico
sul lettering sui caratteri non è una
tesi proprio al mondo del web design
anche se la tipografia vuole svolge un
ruolo fondamentale nel mondo del delle
interfacce beh insomma mi propose questa
tesi sul lettering io accolti con grande
favore perché come sempre vi piace
prendere le tesi dove posso imparare
qualcosa ma non dovessi insegnare tua
gli allievi certo ma il rapporto
scambievole è la natura più importante
di questo lavoro in tutti i casi di
accorsi anche grazie al lavoro di
roberta gennatiempo di come i caratteri
definiscono una terra a volte in un modo
più importante delle bandiere e facciamo
fatto questo giochino di qualche slide
veloce proprio per rendersene conto
insieme chi non si rende conto che
questi sono i bellissimi cangi
giapponesi chi potrebbe non associare
questo a ideogrammi cinesi i bellissimi
io li trovo bellissime caratteri in di
dell'indonesia dell'india verdot
altrettanto bella la scrittura ha
spessore variabile araba
ora è chiaro io parlo da qualcuno che ha
una piccola deformazione una grande
formazione professionale però sincero e
quindi le vedo a modo mio queste cose
però è chiaro che almeno anche non dal
designer tutti quanti ci rendiamo conto
che anche la forma di questi caratteri
definisce una terra per tornare al topic
di oggi in a ma da una modalità più
stretta delle bandiere e per parlare del
il cirillico così aulico così compiuto
rigoroso come un po il rigore russo ci
racconta dicevamo così come ho parlato
di caratteri che definiscono un
linguaggio sempre per continuare il
percorso sulla nostra terra
adesso vado del caso elvetica che cosa
elvetica è un carattere non è una
scrittura che definisce un linguaggio
come quelli prima eppure è un carattere
molto neutro e per via di questa sua
neutralità
se conquistato un territorio nel mondo
della comunicazione fondamentale degli
anni 50 quando è nato e 57 precisamente
nella collaborazione tra hoffman e
meitinger e divenne d'un tratto
nonostante questo carattere non
singolarmente che si chiama elvetica che
viene dalla svizzera è neutra io direi a
questo punto quasi neutrale che anche il
carattere delle mie slide proprio perché
voglio porre l'accento su quello che
dico e non sul carattere delle delle mie
slide dicevo diventa subito il carattere
invece per identificare le cose le
grandi corporation americane le
informazioni
delle metropolitane di new york e entra
in maniera importante nei cartelli anche
delle vetrine nelle etichette dei prezzi
nei bene porta prezzo quindi
incredibilmente un carattere così il
neutro diventa il carattere più
importante per il business e con la mia
tesi st ci accorgemmo di una cosa o
meglio mi accorsi di una cosa gli diedi
la famosa lettura tra le pieghe che è
possibile fare sui nostri territori in
maniera non convenzionale cercando di
prendere la famosa ruote devolverla
questa ruota evoluta nasce dal fatto che
noi un caso alla elvetica a napoli ce
l'abbiamo e un uomo rara anche detto il
numerario perché diciamo non usa la
nostra lingua
che cosa fa o numerare il numerare la
mattina al mercato ortofrutticolo
ovviamente su commessa su richiesta
prepara i cartelli in un lettering molto
sofisticato ed evoluto nel tempo dei
prezzi sono questi qua magari dalle
vostre partite qualcosa di simile o
forse no ma bisogna svegliarsi molto
presto alla mattina infatti per andare a
leggere nelle pieghe della nostra della
nostra terra c'è bisogno di edizioni
roberta che non esista giustamente non
ci va il professore andata alle 4 del
mattino al mercato ortofrutticolo per
vedere all'opera enumerare numeri che
fanno questo lavoro da tempo immemore io
me li ricordo da sempre e hanno
sviluppato davvero una caratteristica
grafica particolare annotiamo la forma
del carattere la forma del carattere una
forma volutamente allegra molto eyes
l'inter cioè si sviluppa molto in
verticale al tempo stesso arrotondata i
colori sono primari non voglio dire una
cosa brutta cattiva che suggerisce po ci
rende più inclini all'acquisto ma un po
è così e allora dove sta l'evoluzione
l'evoluzione sta nel fatto che qualcuno
a napoli dei type designer su questa
base oggi stanno creando un carattere
che nasce proprio da questo concetto
dell'evoluzione anche grazie al mio
aiuto
stanno tirando giù stanno buttando giù
stanno mettendo su me e devo fare un
carattere non ha proprio una una così è
un processo molto più sofisticato di
quello che si crede da un carattere che
nasce solo per questo per gli scontrini
per le etichette per i prezzi nelle
vetrine che si è abituati a vedere
proprio basandosi su questa
caratteristica di non nobile diciamocelo
di di simpatia di invoglia all'acquisto
che ha proprio questa forma questa forma
che non nasce così casualmente ed è
questo quello che io intendo quando
parlo dell'evolvere la ruota delle
nostre terre questo però richiede
dedizione richiede la capacità di
guardare le cose con modo diverso
richiede uno spirito critico
ultimo appunto non nasce in realtà
sempre dall'integrazione collaterale
dimenticavo c'è una cosa bellissima di
buono di bruno murari che dice che il
sogno dell'artista è quello di arrivare
al museo il sogno di un designer quello
di arrivare ai mercatini rionali
pensate enumerare non sono arrivati ai
mercatini rionali ci sono nati quindi
sono quanto più possibile vicino a
quello che per dargli un termine più
gradevole il business di quanto non un
prodotto che alla fine arriva sul dopo
la progettazione anche dell'identity va
e quant'altro mercato rionale
ultima annotazione sempre sulla sulla
terra io sono appassionato di
videogiochi online in particolare di
giochi di ruolo e ho pensato che un nome
fantasy bellissimo per il mio prossimo
personaggio di questi giochi di ruolo
online potrebbe essere fieramosca
[Applauso]
grazie assai